Evet
bugün ki konuşmamda da aslında iki ayrı
bir konuşma yapacağım önceki yarısında
ilk altı dakikada kendi sıfırımı nasıl
bir yaptığımı iki bölümünde ise
konuşmanın sizlerin sıfır olarak görünen
bazı şeyleri nasıl bir yapmanız
gerektiğini Anlatmaya çalışacağım ve
bunu daha çok dişi hukuku o zaman da
yapacağım şimdi
Benim küçüklüğümde
şimdiki gençlerin sahip olduğu
imkanların Aslında pek çoğu yoktu şu
Bizler sırasında yazılan birlikte Neyse
gibi ansiklopedilerden nelerin olup
bittiğini öğrenebiliyoruz internetten
önemi yok Veli Küçük Peki en büyük
hayalim benim dönemindeki çocukların en
çoğunu hayali buydu astronot olmaktı ve
bunun için astronotların hikayelerini
incelediğimde büyük çoğunluğunun
dondurma pilotu olduğunu çünkü bu
dilimlerine
jetleri indirip kaldırma çok zor bir iş
olduğunu daha sonra test pilotu daha
sonra nasıl ettiklerini öğrenmiştim ve
bu nedenle bendee biradaki değil
Sitesi'ne girmekle ilgili de tabi çok
zorlu bir süreçti ama Bunu başardım Bir
de ben istiyordu ama okurken askerlik
mesleğinin çok da benim hayal ettiğim
gibi olmadığını ve bana göre olmadığını
gördüm Çünkü gençler artık arkadaş şöyle
bir kız arkadaşları da yazışırken
WhatsApp kullanırlar bizim zamanımızda
mektup yazarlardı birbirine Tabi biz bir
Yatılı okulda olduğumuz ve erkeklerden
kurulu yok olduğu için öyle bir
sevgilimiz yoktu öyle küçük noktalar
yapıp bir tüp yazacak bunun yanında Öyle
bir dünyamız böyle bir zamanımızda yoktu
çünkü işte pantolon ütüsü bozuk düzgün
selam vermedin saç tıraşı şöyle oldu
diye sürekli savunma verirlerdi ve bu
savunmalara sürekli Daha doğrusu bize
iddialı bulunan Bu arada disiplin
yönetmeliğini ihlal ettiğiniz için biz
de sürekli savunma kazandı dolu ise Ben
hep şunu söyledim ben gençliğimi
sevgilileri mektup yazmak yerine hep
savunma kağıtları yazmakla geçirdim Şu o
sırada kısa dönem askerliğini yaptığı
gelen şöhretli o zaman 8aylık sıram
askerlik yapmaya giden çok düzgün abiler
vardı ve onlarla konuştuğumda Hepsi bu
Kulesi okuduğunu öğren ve benim kafamda
hukuk fakültesi okumak iki ortaya çıktı
Bir ise içinde Barbie okuluna gitmiş i
hukuk fakültesine girdi ve orada
istediğim şuraya Türkiye'nin 12 en iyi
Hukuk Fakültesi hangisi ise ona girmek
ve babamın hukukçu olan arkadaşların
hepsi bana İstanbul Hukuk Fakültesi
Türkiye'nin Fakültesi ilk kullanıp
Fakültesi'ndeki Bence hala öyle bunun
üzerine sınava çalıştım ve İstanbul
hukuk fakültesine girdim arkadaşlar
İstanbul hukuk fakültesine girdiğimde
gerçekten büyülendim bu dünyanın
ihtişama bilen hocaların giyimi kuşamı
davranışı Türkiye'nin çatladı Koskoca
profesörler size Siz diye hitap ediyordu
bir soru sorduğunuzda Bunun mutlaka
ayrıntılı ve düzgün cevaplar veriyorlar
yani sizi insan yerine adam yerine
koyuyorlar ve daha bir sınıftayken Ben
hukuk profesörü olmaya karar ver İki
sınıfa geçtiğimizde ise ilk aldığımız
derslerden birisi ceza hukuku ders
iyiydi ceza hukuku dersi beni gerçekten
büyüledi Çünkü hukuk temel olarak özel
köpek o hukuk olarak ikiye ayrılır özel
hukukta bir değerle bireylerin ilişkisi
kamu hukukunda ise bireylerle devletin
ilişkisi ele alınır Böyle devletin
ilişkisi ilk içecektir bunun üzerine
ceza kutusu olmaya karar verdim ama çok
zor yumuşak meşakatli diyorlar ben
olacağını demekle olmuyor ve burada
öncelikle şunu dikkate aldım hemen ya Bu
bir öğrenci olur ise Hocaların bir
şekilde Dikkatini çekerim beni çekeyim
Ben 14'ü seni gerçekten bu çalışarak
geçirdim Ama şunu söyleyeyim keyif aldım
hemen hasta hobi mi yaptım Ne istediğimi
öğrendim yoldur senin sonunda Okulu
dereceyle bitirince gerçekten de
hocalarının dikkatini çektim ve bir beni
ceza hocasıyla tanıştırdılar aynı
zamanda insan hakları hukuk alanında da
çalışıyordu Ve hem Hoca'nın yanında
stajını yapmaya avukatlık stajını
yapmaya İstanbul resimde yüksek lisans
eğitimine başladı orada yine bir şans ve
hangi okulda olduğunuz ne olduğunuz bu
anlamda son derece önemli O ileri
görüşlü hocalarımız bize Bilişim hukuku
alanında çalışmamızı tavsiye etti zaten
o geçmişler bir gelen işte Astronot
olmak istemesinin teknolojiye olan
merakı nedeniyle sürekli teknolojik
aletleri ile ilgili merakım var idi bu
hukukla birleşince iki sevdim alanı bu
durumda birleştirmiş olduk Peki bu neyi
fark ettirdi 24 senesinde yüksek lisans
tezini soğudum 2004'ün ekiminde de Türk
Ceza Kanunu değişti ve yeni değişen
kanun yeni gelen sistemle bilişim
suçları alanında yazılmış ilk yüksek
lisans tezi ve basılan kitap bir kitabın
oldu Böylelikle Aslında akademik devam
ince olmayacak bir şekilde ben çok geniş
bir akademisyen Ken her konuşmaya Ben
çağrıları başladım Her toplantıya Ben
çağırdım başladım Bu konuda bir rapor
hazırlanacak sa Ben çağırmaya başladı ve
bir anda herkes beni tanımaya başladı
sürekli şunu bir işti yapıyorsanız ya
iyisini yapın yada hiç yapmayın bunu
yüksek lisans tezinde de bunu doktora
tezinde de bunu doçentlik tezini de bunu
şu an hazırlanmakta olduğunu sürelerinde
olmasını bekliyorum Bu söyle vaktim
çalışmamda yaptım diğer ben de yaptım
Her ne yapıyorsanız iyisini yapmaya
çalışın ve ve istediğiniz amaç için
gerçekten istikrarlı bir şekilde
çalışırsanız başarılı olmak gibi bir
ihtimal yok Ben bunun canlı örneği
Tabiki benim okuduğum okulda bir devlet
okulu ama çok özel yokluğu uzun
üniversitede öyleydi ama bunun dışında
ekstra imkanlarım yoktu o imkanları
benden çalışarak Yarattım
bana şunu söylediler Etrafındaki
insanlar ya Sen ne kadar zekisin Sen ne
kadar zekisin bu zekilik kavramını
kesinlikle uretmiyor olan insan
Albert Einstein gibi bir insan olurdu
veye fazla Say gibi çok ünlü bir sanatçı
olur Hayır ben sıradan bir insanım ama
beni diğer insanlardan ayıran en önemli
özellik herhangi bir konuda
odaklandığımda hiçbir şekilde başından
ayrıldılar mı istik bu şekilde uzun süre
çalışabiliyor Dolayısıyla başarı elde
etmek istiyorsanız hayatta o sıfır gibi
görünen şeyleri bir yapmak Hatta daha da
fazlasını yapmak istiyorsanız Sebat
etmeni İstiklal bu olmalı ve çok
çalışmalısınız Diğer yandan Şimdi derim
gençlerin durumuna gençler ne yapmalı
arkadaşlar hangi mesleği yaparsanız
yapın Bilişim teknolojilerini öğrenmek
bilişim teknolojileri ile arkadaş olmak
dost olmak zorundasınız zaten
şanslısınız bugün geliştirilip büyük bir
çoğunluğu dijital doğan insanlar benim
kızım okuma yazma bilmiyordu benim
testlerim yazdığı Masaüstü
bilgisayarımın da explore girip yıldızlı
yerlerden kendi oyun oynayacağı elbise
giydirme prenses giydirme oyunlarını
oynayacağız yani açık giriyordu Hiçbir
zaman olabilecekleri bunu tableti
bilgisayarı nasıl Ben göremedim Tam
tersine ben Yeni telefon aldım da ona
veriyorduk sen şunu bir kuruluyordu
benim belki bir gün yapacağım işi 10
dakikada Grup 3. cep telefonu bana
veriyordu hala böyleyim Bu nedenle çok
çok
haklısınız ama dünya artık İnternet
ağırlaştı bilgisayar çağında açtı sosyal
medya çağında açtı kişisel verdiği canı
taştı insanlık sonra arkadaşlar kuşak
Yapay Zeka çağına doğru gidiyor Yapay
Zeka çağına doğru ilerliyor ve yapay
zekalar sizin ileride yapmayı
planladığınız işlere sizin elinizden
almaya adaylar
Dolayısıyla yapmanız gerek bir bilişim
teknolojileri konusunda gerçekten bilgi
sahibi olmanız iki yapay zekaları
öğrenmeniz 3 ve önemlisi yaratıcı işler
yapmamız örneğini ele alalım
biraz tuhaf o çalışıyor Eskiden mu 20
kişiydi Bu arada o 20 kişinin 10 tane
Siri Yargıtay kararı Arar şimdi hale
Arar bilimsel bir yayına lar daha önce
yazılmıştır Rapor alan mütala ara 12 şu
an kutluyorsun da yok bu diye çünkü
hukuk yazılımları sayesinde artık size
edilen çeşitli programlarda anahtar
kelimeleri girerek bugüne kadar
yayınlanmış bütün Yargıtay kararlarından
bütün Anayasa Mahkemesi kararlarında
bütün buluşlar kararlarında çizin
ilgilendiğimiz alana ilişkin olanların
tamamını okuyorsunuz Hatta o kararların
özetlerini yapıldığı için karın tamamını
dağıtmak zorunda kalmıyorsunuz özetini
okuyorsunuz Ne oldu Onu ihtiyaç kaldım
Hayır eskiden olan kişinin ihtiyaç vardı
niye abiyeleri gidip oluşturmaları
gerekiyordu Isparta dairelerinde
mahkemelerde artık gerek yok Niye ulusal
yargı ağı projesi var Elektronik imzanız
da oturduğunuz yerden gece 12'de kadar
her tür bu işlemi yapabiliyorsunuz her
türlü için yükle biliyorsunuz Eskiden
Postacılar vardı bize basılı tebligat
getirirlerdi artık yok elektronik
tebligat lan bütün teskilattaki konuşma
yapmış olduk bilgisayara geliyor görüyor
musunuz Kaç tane kişinin iş gücü azaldı
eki Yarın bizi ne bekliyor Şimdi 10 tane
kişi var işte 10 tane kişinin pek çoğu
dilekçe yazıyorlar Tamam kararları
topluyor ama ben savunmuştu derisini
oluşturuyorum duruşmaya çıkıp Ben zaten
savunmayı yapıyorum o bile gitme
yazılması lazım O raporların
hazırlanması lazım onları toparlayıp
yapıyorlar al bir Yapay Zeka devreye
girdiğinde ki Amerika'da ve Avrupa'da bu
yazılımları artık kullanılıyor o Güneş
çelebibaği zeka yazacağım ve o
raporlarda Yapay Zeka yazacak Ben yalnız
da gerekli yerlerde müdahale edeceğim ve
insani ilişkinin kurulması gereken yerde
bölüm insan ilişki kuracağını insan
insan etinin alınması gereken yerde ben
olacak Ne oldu bugünkü On kişinin yedi
tanesi daha eşsiz kaldı mı ile kaldık üç
kişi yaratıcı iş yapan iş kişi insanın
yapabileceği iş yapan kişi Dolayısıyla
sizi böyle bir gelecek bir yok
yaratıcılık tarafınızı geliştirmeniz
şart ve yapay zeka yazılımını kullanmayı
bilmiyorsanız bilişim teknolojileri
kullanmayı bilmiyorsanız bunu İmam Hatip
olarak işlerinizde nasıl kullanacağınızı
nasıl geliştireceğiniz bilmiyorsanız
ilerlemeniz mümkün değil bu hukuk değil
isterseniz Ekim olun bugün yakın
gelecekte Patoloji patolog kalmayacak
Çünkü Yapay Zeka
yazılımları patologlar dan çok daha iyi
kanser hücreleri tespit ediyorlar o
cerrahi devrede uzaktan erişim de
ameliyat yapılıyor veya sanat notaları
geliyorsunuz mükemmel çalışıyorlar Hatta
o yüzden araya atalı kodlar geliyor ki o
İnsanlar insanlardan sadır olan hatalar
olsun diye Dolayısıyla
gördüğünüz gibi vereceğin tamamı işimi
yapar ister arada hangi işi yaparsanız
yapın bugün futbolda bile var diye bir
sistem var gerçekten penaltı mı
gerçekten olsaydı buna bakılıyor
sizlerden beklentimiz
ülkemizi ve insanlığı ve tabii kendinizi
ileriye taşımanız kendisi fırınımızı bir
yapmanız Böylelikle toplum olarak
sıfırdan bile doğru yükselebilmek bunu
almanız için de mutlaka ve mutlaka
bilişim teknolojileri ile dost arkadaş
kardeş olmanız onlarla işbirliği
yapmamız gerekiyor